so what we do with Rio is that we cut
out the middleman kind of like still the
street concept we cut out the middleman
the Wall Street investment bankers the
underwriter intermediaries and we go
directly we bring offerings or
securities directly to the public so we
like to say we can get you in on the
crop that they won't share mmm which
we're totally your back office we handle
all the the business of cannabis for you
and manage that train hire fire all of
that the record-keeping the taxes and so
on and so on and if your expertise was
growing cannabis that can remain your
expertise when liens are historians
tales of the hunt we're no longer
favored the hunter know someone's
opinion may contradict yours what is my
friend Alan it's all about your
perspective who are we and what is the
nature of this reality what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don sake on we're on site at the
beautiful new West Summit we are now
going to be talking with Melek Dexter hi
Malik how you doing thank you so much
for coming on the show no problem I'm
still pumped for this conversation Melek
is the CEO and founder of Repub and his
backgrounds so interesting here the
dexterous understanding of racial
dynamics moved him to foundry up which
is a crowdsource startup that leverages
diversity as a competitive
differentiator in the cannabis industry
and it's been cool thing I heard that
this is part of the slogan and I talked
to you about this a bit in the green
room but from the streets to the
boardroom I love that a lot we got a lot
to unpack here let's talk about you
first you know who are you how did you
even get started on this journey okay
again thank you for being for allowing
me to be here
my name is Dex Melek Dexter and the way
I came about this is
is really organic in the sense of I
found myself in search of I would call
like a cure my older brother had a scar
on his brain or has a scar on his brain
and later in life he developed these
seizures and we were told that one day
ultimately they will kill him so I began
my trek you know to the west coast from
the South Atlanta and in search of what
I've been hearing is this oil that you
know could treat that and we were very
aware of just how how vicious you know
the regular conventional medicine you
know was so I found it and began to my
brother older brother had smoked weed
all his life but that didn't seem to
affect the situation so after a while of
treating himself you know with strong
THC you know content all in those early
days the seizures went like from mild to
to not happening so uh while out there
you know but what I saw I had never seen
anything like it I saw Humboldt County
and at that time it was very white and
and and I'm I was raised in a way where
I'm very keen to racial dynamics you
know I think it feeds into everything
you know whether we see it say it or not
it's there and so I noticed that the
black people in home boat wouldn't make
eye contact and I I assumed that that
was I don't want to mess up my plug you
know so overtime of buying and selling
you know while I was out there I
realized that I was in the game and and
my white counterparts were in in
business I was selling weed and they
were selling cannabis and so I knew that
wasn't gonna end well for me and I was
not gonna be on the cover of a magazine
as a result of you know my prowess and
act business acumen I was gonna wear you
know some county orange somewhere and so
with that being the case I knew
personally I knew enough
people who look like me and didn't fit
the the the drug dealer stereotype and
so that's what found it that's what led
me to say we've got to rethink this my
father always told me you know we have
to out think they're thinkers and so I
began the process of out thinking and
that led ultimately to to you know
realizing until 2012 President Obama
introduced the JOBS Act and the
significance of that is that prior to
2012
you could not if you unless you were an
accredited investor with a net worth of
a million dollars or an earning that
yearly earning of $250,000 you couldn't
invest into private equity companies and
private equity companies could not raise
money from that group of people who were
less than that and so this was a game
changer in and how you know smaller
companies could could crowdfund how they
could raise money different from like a
Series A Series B you had the regulation
DS and the Reg A's and so on and so on
so we thought to leverage the marijuana
industry by using these these are these
these personal offering exemptions
private offering exempt exemptions and
how to raise capital so what we do with
three up is that we cut out the
middleman it's kind of like still the
street concept we cut out the middleman
the Wall Street investment bankers the
underwriter intermediaries and we go
directly we bring offerings or
securities directly to the public so we
like to say we can get you in on the
crop that they won't share mmm yeah okay
so first this
I love the perception that you have you
have this perspective when you get into
Humboldt that you see that it's either
I'm in the game or I'm in the business
and I love that first that perception is
hey I want in on the business I want to
democratize these fruits that are about
to come from the emerging cannabis
market to to black people I want to
democratize them to women I want to
democratize
two people that typically don't actually
get the privilege of reaping the best
parts of the emerging market fruits and
that's such a critical part of the
conversations that we've been having and
this other one is about you know micro
financing that parts so crucial as well
people that only have ten bucks a
hundred bucks a thousand bucks can they
get in on the emerging market and how
can we most easily make the regulatory
frameworks that enable that style of
process
well well our approach is uh I think
it's very fair and also unique in the
sense that we operate from a very
conscious position of knowing that at 33
states now having legalized in some
shape or form
you know cannabis that if no one stopped
at the halfway mark to say oh my god
we've left out you know black people
again even though they suffered from the
war on drugs then that's the business as
usual so operating with that type of
consciousness we're very specific and
not trying and we're very specific in
our plan as to what we want to do so
individuals with $10 or whatever we're
encouraging them you know to put their
monies together to pool their resources
even amongst their own you know networks
and and to go larger you know in an
effort to to reap the windfall of this
this you know this big industry the
mindful of the mindset change from that
that extra hundred dollars being used on
a material possession that is just
trying to be in a sense just
conspicuously flaunted rather than
investing that into the long game into
this big game into emerging market this
is financial literacy so many people
actually you know Daymond John has been
stepping up and talking about this a lot
recently these financial literacy things
that were not taught so much in school
but especially can we get the the young
black kids around the United States to
really latch
into that in yeah well let me say this
about it's not financial illiteracy
that's the assumption we talk about the
need to teach financial literacy it's
not that there's a illiteracy we have to
be mindful that there there's always
been a plan to create a vulnerable
population to be exploited and in this
country it's black people is they're the
primary target so it's not we're not
combating this is not a matter of
fighting illiteracy yeah it's it's it's
a game I was not I didn't have the
choice to choose the game or the
business I was doing business you know
I'm a very highly educated person but
regardless of me doing the same
transaction I was put in the game based
upon my race so the concept of
illiteracy is is where you're socially
designated so our mission is not to
create you know financial literacy is to
give the opportunity 80% of the
marijuana that is grown in California
prior to just a few years ago left
California and and I would venture
because the data is only you know
empirical I would venture that a large
amount of that marijuana left California
through highly sophisticated networks
that black people ran this is why you
have to look at I think a Baron
Rothschild made this statement that you
know at the Battle of Waterloo there
that you invest when there's blood in
the streets but people only stop you
know at that point the reality is he
said that you invest when there's blood
in the streets even if it's your own so
the blood in the streets in America
today is the the highness arrest rates
and how disproportionate that is of
black to everyone else but there's a way
to look at that as as a businessperson
if black people nationwide are five
times more likely to be arrested with
marijuana then what that really means
you could there's a discrimination
position that can be taken in social
justice but there's another side of a
person's reading the what the market
what that simply means is that black
people got we you see yeah so that 80%
leaves means that we actually were
responsible for a large part of the
marijuana industry and the way that it
moved the way that it was trafficked in
the way that it was distributed so the
effects of the legalization process
across the country and it's
systematically shutting us out is akin
to a national campaign to gentrify our
networks of distribution and create the
Walmart effect meaning that when Walmart
hits your city mom-and-pops die and so
that's what's happening now and then
with the way social equity is playing
out is that we're losing what we were
already doing to the first move
advantage you know of white wealthy
males so it's not it's not really about
illiteracy that's the that's or a
knee-jerk reaction yeah you know of not
being really in tune it's actually an
insulting position thank you for
educating me more on that and that's
really strong actually so okay so we
have this history of rules and
regulations and just overall game plans
that have put certain populations of
people at disadvantages from this
growing pot of wealth that's being
created and then furthermore is that you
know these lines actually really
resonate with me it's you know yay has a
line where he says that meanwhile the
DEA teamed up with the CCA
corporate Corrections of America and so
when you have things like that happening
you see these greater incarceration
rates you educate us here about the
distribution network if the distribution
network is more black why is there not
inclusive stake holding that is making
it so that they reap the rewards of the
distribution that that's the literacy
that we're teaching I like this a lot so
rather than having this massive
conglomerate that's owned by white male
America coming in and and having the
Walmart effect happen how do we make the
process where the distribution networks
have inclusive stake holding added to
them as quickly as possible so that way
we can have that this literacy in a
sense movement happen if inclusive stake
holding which then makes it so that
people can reap the Ben
it's of the fruits of the emerging
market I don't think it can be done you
know and I don't think that's the
incentive there is no financial you know
upside of doing that for the people you
the the purpose of business in
capitalism is that you win and some a
greater amount of people lose that's
that's the way it's based so I don't
think that that system is meant to be
undone and it certainly won't be undone
by the people who are benefiting from it
and so there lies always growing and
it's just the the majority of the people
that are investing in the pie earlier
aargh reaping most of the fruits
meanwhile the bottom is just very slowly
coming up in terms of basic needs
yeah that's what's happening but there's
no there's no precedent of any industry
doing that I mean you can look at the
alcohol industry right I forget the guys
name what's the brothers name who with
the Jack Daniels you know this this this
guy who literally taught Jack Daniels
how to create the brew met Malcolm
nearest mouth and so after all this time
they're giving him a brand but they're
not going back in in retrospect you know
in retroactive League
adding that up and giving him any type
of you know repairing there's nothing
nothing happened like that so there's no
precedent in any industry you know where
someone is gone and done that so what
reopen is is that we are not we're our
own social equity program we're going to
leverage the JOBS Act and take
securities directly to the community at
large and not just the wealthiest and
our networks you know we don't need
5,000 licenses you know like like the
big MS O's or anything like that we just
need what we're able to obtain in that
industry in this industry and then we
can redistribute wealth amongst
ourselves and then establish that yeah
and I ER and Oni rest' green Oh
interesting
okay so nearest Nathan nearest Green
interesting okay was a blackhead Stiller
commonly referred to now as a master
distiller born into slavery emancipated
after the Civil War he's known as the
master distiller who taught distilling
techniques to Jack Daniel founder of the
Jack Daniel Tennessee whiskey distillery
so nearest green as a master distiller
taught Jack Daniel the techniques that
are now literally known as one of the
most popular whiskeys and where is the
inclusive stake holding for the net for
the nearest family exact so stuff like
that this these are the points to me
there's no historical precedent of that
and then we can go back to the numbers
game in Harlem you know which when
licensing came into effect it left from
it start it stopped being a black thing
and became you know owned by the state
we can go back to gambling which was
thriving in the Chicago the Detroit's
and all these places then it became Las
Vegas it's it's that's the process so
that's part of the literacy that you
refer to is that we we need to remind
you know black people in the presence in
other words we're centering blackness
you know and them in the black plight in
our conversations and when we talk to
audiences outside of ours that's where
the illiteracy takes place because we
have to remind you that this is where
these things started and I'm sure as you
do your research we all do our research
we're gonna find a nearest you know in
the cannabis industry we don't teach
Cheech and Chong the whole stereo yeah
is about a swarthy looking person who
most likely is is Hispanic and or other
but not the typical a typical you know
white male yeah so then you got Bob
Marley Peter Tosh it's just the way hip
hop in a few years won't look like the
it's not run by the originators of it so
we're not
program is simply very clear and
transparent and it's not to say that you
know why people cannot support or
anything like that you're supporting us
by helping us get the message out so
we're just centering black so that we
can have a real conversation about
what's really happening what really has
happened and use the historical
precedent of has there ever been any
desire to socially you know make people
equal yeah and I say no it has and could
Rena re-up and other movements that are
focusing on this inclusive stake holding
leveraging the the being able to take
and break down the what used to be just
a million dollar investment into such
smaller components enabling that equity
is massive also there was the the we
were doing this more and more actually
it's coming up not only here in the
conversation within the Earth's nearest
nearest green nathan nearest green but
also it without the unknown the unknown
heroes is the one with the three NASA
computers the females that were
computers yeah is that what was the
movie again something faces oh he didn't
figures like that right hidden figures
the hidden figures yes so hidden figures
was another great example of this so
this is also a call in terms of you
teaching us about literacy its teaching
its getting people more excited to learn
about where were these unknown hidden
figures in the past that have literally
moved fields forward that never got to
reap the rewards for themselves and
their families along the way and so I
love that point that's critical so now
let's talk about the framework of Rio so
yeah so how exactly are do you guys
figure out to to be able to make it
easily accessible for people and how are
you marketing yourself so people know
about you and then changing their mind
to invest in well the SEC as we know as
Securities Exchange Commission is a
highly regulated entity so we plan on
doing this with what's called a reg a
tier to raise capital raise
and what that means is that rank Reggae
plus rank a tier two RIT reggae plus
tier two plus tier two and that gives us
the ability to to raise capital from
accredited and non-accredited
individuals up to the point of fifty
million dollars in a 12-month period so
our plan is there's another concept in
there and the sec whenever you do
capital raises with non-accredited
people there's a great assumption and
the sec uses the word sophisticated
investor it makes the the very
racialized statement that wealthy people
are sophisticated or smart so and then
it there's a requirement that these
individuals have to have a relate you
have to have a pre-existing relationship
with them in order to raise the money so
we've created something like an
investment syndicate an online community
tool we're in the process of creating
that and so when we invite people in
there's a process of education
orientation exposure to the
conversations like this like through
series of videos or magic yes uriel kind
of like a master class that's the class
yeah cool so individuals learn more
about the type of investment there are
actual origins and their stake that that
was in the industry as originators such
as nearest green those kind of examples
and so when we after a period of time of
doing that and networking with these
individuals we've been traveling to the
cities so the plan is roughly you know
10 cities I'm calling them chocolate
cities cities were predominantly there's
a strong you know black population and
the reason for that is that as
legalization has moved from the west we
noticed that it started or it moved very
quickly to recreational but as it's
moving to the Midwest and to the south
it starts as medicinal and and so that
medicinal within itself adding to the
already existing almost non-negotiable
barriers of entry the fact that it's
medicinal makes it very difficult to
because then the prereq is that you
would have
be an operator have would have had to
have massive public health experiment
experience dealing with an entire state
so that rules out you know mom and pops
or another black individual who just got
money who has money so we're watching
that and we're noticing that so a way
for us to to you know to counter that
situation is by pooling the monies
nationwide so what we've doing done is
we've looked at like 10 cities and the
goal is if we could raise that we're not
locked into this because we have
different denominations of people's
ability to contribute but roughly just
so we can show how doable the number is
the 50 millionaires in ten cities a
thousand people who give $5,000 that's
50 million dollars and then we invest
with those individuals that say a
company ten cities 1,000 people 5,000
dollars that's 50 million that's so now
we have buying power there it is we're
our own social equity program as opposed
to waiting for what takes place so
that's the that's that's the process and
we function not as an MSO
but something like a CMO a cannabis
management organization you see in the
dental industry there's DSOs and what
they do is they provide back office you
know services and management services
hiring and firing human resource and so
on and so on to dental offices and so
that's the service will perform because
most individuals who were in the game
now ready to get into the business they
grew it they sold it yeah you know the
that's a different you know thing with
all the regulation and the accounting
and compliance so that's what we provide
for those individuals who have the
license because right now what's
happening in social equity is that the
license are literally purchasable if you
obtain them by the bigger companies and
they keep a black face out for the
purpose of blackface to sustain the
the equity licenses so that's how RIA
will roll out in so we have a we kind of
I think we we serve a greater purpose by
not taking over a person's business but
we provide support so yeah that's that's
the ambition that's the goal epic so
then ten cities a thousand people in
each city five thousand dollars to get
in you guys handle this back-office work
so they don't have to worry so much you
handle the educational piece the
masterclass pieces they get in so they
better understand what's going CMO
cannabis management or the organization
and then what happens with the fund with
the 50 million how does that get
allocated for ensuring excellent returns
right well let's say you you have a
license
we've had several offers from different
places so far that we're actually
considering and having conversations
with let's say in Michigan right now or
Chicago you have a cultivation license
and and processing or extraction license
what we would do is we would we would
assist we would create a contract or
negotiate what the relationship is and
hypothetically speaking let's say we
will purchase the equipment for
extraction we will bring you know highly
trained personnel from who know how to
extract in compliance with that
particular ordinance or that state you
know regulation and we would provide
that training we would provide the the
the set up the negotiate the leases of
the of the particular real estate that
you're using which we're totally your
back office we handle all the the
business of cannabis for you and manage
that train hire fire all of that the
record-keeping the taxes and so on and
so on and if your expertise was growing
cannabis that can remain
expertise and then that you feel a part
of the re-up proceso everyone that's
doing their thing in the cannabis
industry that also puts in is a joint
venture joint venture so we're part
people that's it from all those cities
yes and you manage like a macro
perspective of what's happening between
growers and dispensaries and read the
real estate side and yes transactions
and then giving people dividends as you
guys exactly we handle all of that in so
our investor pool reaps the benefits of
us making sure that we manage you know
the the bottom line of that business who
may never have had to to deal with the
regular regulatory aspects of growing
cannabis extracting cannabis making
edibles selling edibles we handle those
those parts to keep them in compliance
because it's it's it's highly regulated
it's highly regulated everywhere people
it's manifesting differently a matter of
fact in Georgia where we have what's
called HB 324 there are no dispensaries
it's going to be the product will be
dispensed through pharmacies what is
switch is in the whole state of joint
all state of Georgia there are no
dispensary it's gonna be dispensed
through pharmacies yeah so how that's
gonna roll out we no one has any ideas I
don't even know they have who wrote that
legislation it's another good question
yeah who's behind that and why like
what's the what's the agenda behind that
because once again that manifest has an
interesting Lea difficult barrier to
entry for that that black City so uh you
know we have black pharmacists you know
so we're just watching how it goes but
the I think the most significant thing
about Rio is that we're a campaign a
business a movement of of readiness and
readiness is is is interesting because
we participated in the early stages of
as a witness to the early stages of the
social equity program in Oakland and in
San Francisco my critique of these
model social equity programs is that
they are there they're going to the time
it takes for them to have for them to do
to activate what they want to do to
create social equity the game is so far
ahead you know it's so far gone it's
it's beyond you know smoking or whatever
so therefore like I think you mentioned
or I've heard people at the conference
mentioned you know snoop and in other
rappers and such that the only way for
us to participate in the legal industry
is life as though it was still illegal
in other words we participate as in my
opinion as caricature in this business
in this industry whereas our imagery is
still about you know how high we can get
and how blowed we are when we're doing
something as opposed to the medicinal
aspects of it the high science related
to it yeah in the high tech that's going
to be needed you know in it and so like
literally if Snoop was just way more on
the health and wellness side or more on
the high science side or on the hey go
and put in the 5k and to re-up a side of
things yes we would love that you know
our celebrities those individuals who
can kick catch throw and jump you know
sing dance rap but you know join us and
and we have individuals who are in the
process of doing that as influencers to
move us to this particular space and and
let's see what we can do when we do what
we need to do yeah wow that whole the
whole idea of this the caricature is
just it's it's actually permeating into
all different types of people's spirits
like you really it's it's about just
this like inability for creative
flourishing to be optimized like I see I
see this happening time and time again
with emerging markets that instead of
having immediately from the ground up
these the the storytelling everything in
this scenario and if you can story tell
in a way that
lights fires under people's butts to
want to endeavor into the emerging
market more optimally towards the health
and wellness side or towards the high
tech and high science side or towards
the investment side it's just that's
what catalyzes the snowball effect they
tell their friends and stuff but it's
about the stories initially so actually
these these memes that you paint about
what could be are actually one of the
key seeds that need to happen is that
it's a story that needs to be told and
there's no offense to the brothers who
are doing what they're doing it's just
simply it's not personal at them it's
just simply you have a greater voice and
a greater influence you know brothers
like killer Mike and and TI those
individuals and then I understand that
jay-z is in the business as well that's
what needs to happen to bring another
influencing towards you know higher
social justice issues and even adding
the economic you know the opportunity
for economic and generational wealth as
an issue of social justice which it is
you know the right of self-determination
is a social justice issue so I would
like to see more of us turn from signing
our names and receiving a check as
opposed to you know equity being equity
you know but also to source the the
companies that are out here that are
black and and and lend their celebrity
to them and let's move this thing
forward as real influences because
hip-hop is the prime example you know no
one was thinking of touching a record
and moving it back and forth finding and
creating a sound and then but look at
what it became it became a privately
held billion-dollar industry then and
ultimately it was appropriated and now
it is what it is so the precedent of
what we can create is is clearly there
but also the precedent of what happens
you know once we create is is there also
so we have to be mindful of that
that's what Rio is about you know ramai
finding us that we did it we can do it
and what a beautiful place it would be
to do it again and so you know when I
have these conversations in the presence
of white people out my I've always asked
you know so what can we do my my answer
is that you can support and you can
support you can watch you can not work
against what's taking place because it's
inevitable that black people will not
wait for social equity but don't check
yourself to not feel threatened by black
people owned in their own culture it's
natural for a group of people to own
their own culture so what we're simply
doing is we're fractionalized in the
asset of black culture and our
relationship to this planet and we're
rewiring our reaction to it as being you
know victims to it to having victory
over it and creating it into creating an
opportunity for generational wealth and
so what I'm saying to you know our white
peer is that when that happens you get
to experience this once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity of the legalization of
marijuana you get the once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity to be on the right side of
history and not allow this to black
people having wealth and controlling
their wealth to not feel threatening to
you so I like that I like the idea of
creating the generational wealth by in
the sense fractional izing and saying
okay black community let's get ourselves
together in the pieces that we need
together in order to be able to take on
this emerging market and take on the
exponential curve that's coming in to
make it so that we can reap the fruits
of this and make it so that our kids and
their kids get the benefits of what is -
I I'm a huge fan of also the way that
you just portray the the like don't feel
fear about the pie growing and people
stepping in that are in a sense
different from you whether it be we just
came back from three weeks of
partnership interviews in China and
there's way too much crap happening
about people haven't even visited the
countries before and there's hatred
flying around it's like you don't you
got to go and visit make friends and
then you'll see how this is love it's
love and and then you and then it's old
and then it's like let China have their
growing pie let black America have their
growing pie and also grow your own and
your family's pies as well and just uh
and that mentality of not having fear
around that but rather having vast
abundance that just is just so big that
it's able to be shared with everyone is
that's the future that we want to go
plus there's the average the median age
in Africa right now is 18 yeah yeah and
that market it again it's like what are
you gonna do with a billion people
especially young people that have a
youth that have the creative potential
to to take care of things like the
massive rainforests in the Congo that
have the potential to do things like
leverage all the incredible natural
resources that are in the the continent
of Africa but also the the creative
potential of all the philosophical the
scientific ideas that are about to erupt
from in as well so what are your
thoughts about about that I'm interested
here we can think about that I think
that as relates to Africa I think that
Africa is the central ground for the
future I think that Africans and him in
the Western Hemisphere are the most
integral people to the future of Africa
and not to make the continental African
you know my brothers and sisters
insignificant I'm saying that the coming
home you know process the meeting of
those two persons when we began to share
notes yeah it's gonna be a massive thing
and I think the rest of the world is
going to have to watch there's an
interesting guy guys who's taking place
you know whether you agree with Obama's
politics are not a black man as the
leader of the quote-unquote free world
it's highly symbolic
daughter grew up when there was a black
president she doesn't even know anything
about that there was it could be
anything else
spider-man is black in her lifetime so
it's a different philosophy and we were
yet to see the effects of that but we're
kind of seeing it even again back to
hip-hop individuals have figured it out
I don't need to sign a contract I will
point and click and make this video and
then I will tour and I will earn money
people are are cutting out the this this
the slavery process and big big America
corporate America hasn't figured it out
yet and so Africa I always use the
analogy about African this sense that
Africa emerged on the cellphone game
when it was digital never experienced
analog yeah so we're we just don't have
the cameras pointed at Africa you know
to see just how how creative did the
African interlay were the first people
on the planet at this point nobody
denies that except you know bubbling a
couple other guys you know and other
people can't relate you know but there's
something to be said about that a lot to
be said so I think Africa is is by
necessity becoming its own thing it's
like the the quote-unquote market the
modern world a more progressive world is
is running at a breakneck speed and it's
Africa's wisdom to not try and catch up
or feel that it's outdated it's to let
them go ahead and crash into what
they're doing since you mentioned an
international view I think it was the
president of Brazil DaSilva he was
making a comment some years ago about
the whole the world banking institution
that crippled the world for a moment
there you know and he said that he
didn't mean he didn't know any black or
brown bankers he said this world has
been brought to his knees by by
blue-eyed males because they portrayed
that they understood and knew what they
were doing and didn't I only say that to
say is that to answer your question that
Africa is the future but it's not an
Africa under you know this this this New
Age colonial idea of Africa not another
scramble no it's it's an Africa that
that's thinking clearly and thinking and
center in Africa in all of its endeavors
so you can't hold back you know a nation
of youth who are who are who are you you
that's what youth does it creates so yes
I think it's the largest population of a
continent of youth in the world so
there's no way that the world can be the
same with with that being the new
influencers how that's my tape I love
that I love your perspective on the
sharing of notes that will be so
beautiful with that when that happens
that's that's I love that and just the
unlocking of the creative potential so
excited for that there's two questions
that we like asking our guests on the
way out of the show the first question
is do you think that we're in a
simulation explain you a question again
to me do you think that this reality is
a simulation so this is the matrix like
question I think it's a I think it is
simply because it doesn't have to exist
you know we live in the world as you see
it right now is the world that white
males made there's proof there's even
the concept itself admitting to say that
there's the first world second we're in
the third world and actually it's the
other way around third world countries
most likely are the first world
countries and so the the simulation in
in map from my perspective is the
thought that America is a first world
country when it's not a first world
culture so yes I agree that it's a
simulation and would it be that the the
quote-unquote these third world
countries would it be that they're
moment-to-moment
a duration of existence is that's why
it's the that's why that would be like
the first world versus being caught in
the economic machinery in the first
world is
where why would you select that the
third world is actually the first world
because you mean just historically it
was here first you know Africa was here
first so all the perceptions of world
and culture and people and humanity
would have come from the first people
it's just simple my my children know
that I created them by virtue of just
you know I've always been there
so the first world has concepts of
having been first that just it's just
it's just a matter of who's telling the
story so I think there's a there's a a
freaking proverb that you know when
Lions are historians tales of the hunt
we're no longer favor the hunter that's
that's it yeah that's a great product I
like that yeah okay and then the last
question is what do you think is the
most beautiful thing in the world free
black people even you like free blacks
you you love it you love to see us doing
what we do you authentically you know I
always say the the fist bump is much
cooler than a half I look at you see so
us being free and you being able to
interact with us in our most authentic
selves ultimately it relaxes you okay so
the more we enter it's gonna be hard for
a generation or two to have the pictures
of us on the wall being what we are and
listening to the music to then walk away
and do what their fathers have done I'm
certain through time and osmosis of that
of that interaction is that that won't I
think white kids are waking up and
realizing that they've been lied to
also and it's happening yeah it's
happening so that to me that's the most
beautiful thing in the world I love it I
love it this in addition to my two
daughters
that I love this the vision of what we
see in like a United Nations where we
have representation of people from Asia
people from Europe people from Latin
America people from Africa women like
when we see stuff like that in the
cannabis industry or the blockchain and
cryptocurrency space all these emerging
markets that are happening that's when
we can tell that there's true equity of
the fruits being distributed I don't
know about that but you know that
diversity is there is an appearance as
when people use it right now it's like a
quota or an appearance the true
diversity is not people showing up in
appearing the true diversity is people
show up as they are and do what they do
and receive what they receive in an
equitable way you're not the appearance
yeah because you can you can totally you
can place a bunch of people here okay
look but can I bore yeah yeah of course
yeah a white guy in Africa who takes his
picture with the black children he looks
diversified but he gets on a plane and
he leaves and whatever he created or
whatever he did or people who look like
him did he leaves the situation as it is
so a lot of these companies are striving
for diversity as a photo-op that's what
that's the the caricature of the past
and of the future is when it actually is
all those people have roles they're
actually filling in a meritocracy in
those positions that would be that's in
there in there as their selves not as
you know ceremonially photo-op yeah yeah
yeah that's it all right thanks so much
this is so fun what a great episode
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate you'd love to hear our
thoughts in the comments bowl in the
episode let us know what you're thinking
check out the links in the bio to re-up
and to Malik's work check out all of
those links everyone check out the links
in the bow to new West Summit I'll
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the leaders in your communities that you
believe in help them flourish you can
find all of our links below as well and
the future everyone manifests your
dreams into the world we love you very
much thanks for tuning in and we will
see you soon all right that's a wrap
guys good job
that was so fun foreshadows thank you
thank you
[Music]
you